this is served to only further inflamed
tensions North Korea tried to put this
first spy satellite into space at 629
local time from its West Coast but it
lost thrust mid-air due to engine
failure and fell into the sea between
South Korea and China and it set off
alarm Bells quite literally in South
Korea and Japan about 25 million people
in Seoul waking up to the sound of Air
Raid Sirens told to prepare for a
possible evacuation then in Okinawa in
Japan people were also told to take
shelter fortunately this fire satellite
had failed but it probably will raise
concerns and questions
um about how much those systems can be
trusted and now the actions by North
Korea were swiftly condemned by the US
and Japan and South Korea called it a
serious problem education and a great
violation of the UN resolutions what's
particularly striking I think was how
quick North Korea admitted failure with
this but it has vowed to conduct a
second launch as soon as possible it
says that a reliable reconnaissance
information system is needed to keep a
grip on enemy military activities in
real time citing joint exercises between
South Korea and the US